Hello Freak bitches.
So after you got through this,
yeah.
What made you do four and five?
The carrot of like,
just wait a little,
make sense.
Here's what they do.
They set up that you're the auditor now,
so you're,
you're auditing these things in your body.
You're now the boss.
So they go,
they tell you,
get your head on like your,
it's your job.
You don't need to believe anything.
You just need to audit them.
So you need to do your job as an auditor.
That's what they're called.
Auditor's people who are the ones who take you into session and Scientology,
right?
So you feel like you're in a leadership role.
So you're doing these things a favor,
you know,
and you're like,
well,
maybe it's true.
I don't know.
I mean,
I do sometimes hear voices and you know,
like,
you know,
you have a moment with yourself and you're like,
I might be really kind of crazy.
Um,
so you're like,
maybe this was an answer.
It's,
it's sick because it speaks to a side of you that wants answers about life,
you know?
And then you're like,
no,
this is some crazy shit,
man,
that there wasn't even the people that what?
No,
you know it it.
Listen,
you believe what you want to believe at the time.
Does it feel to you at the moment,
like maybe if you just keep going,
it'll get better.
And I'm confused now,
but if I contemplate this and I write it over,
eventually I'm going to receive enough information,
right?
This is all going to be like,
oh right.
I was a fool.
I didn't understand.
Right?
So for example,
one time I had talked to a friend about it,
I said,
you know,
I heard some of us,
some Xenu Shit.
She,
she pulled me into celebrity center so fast into a secured room and she handed
me my ass.
She said,
don't you ever say that word outside of secured room?
I'm writing a knowledge report on you.
She said,
I'm writing room.
You never say that word out loud in a room that's not secured.
Okay.
And never seen again.
So she wrote a report on the report.
She wrote a knowledge report on me.
I got sent to what's called ethics,
which is like the Justice Department of celebrities of,
of Scientology.
And they said,
they brought me into another secured room because they have to get somebody who
knows this information.
And they said,
never ever say that w say this.
It never confirm it.
Never deny it.
Never give that information out ever.
That just never discuss it.
Just say I'd never heard of it.
You sound crazy.
Wow.
And then I also,
this is all just theories of course,
and I'm not going to research any of this,
but,
um,
I think parents try to outdo each other with their stories about what the fuck
they felt.
And it's just like,
they're really,
they're really like,
they're not saying people,
most parents know.
And I've learned to kind of already be like,
um,
they'll just sit down next to you,
like your Forrest Gump and they'll just sit down and just start talking to you.
So he just said,
your kid,
all right,
well this is what you got to watch out for.
You know what?
I remember my kid and Blah,
blah,
blah blah,
dude.
It's like airplane.
You know what I mean with with a fucking person,
he talks to them and you want to kill yourself.
Just wait until he started going to school.
Ooh.
Then you've got to,
you've got to hang out with these parents all the time.
Your kid's become
friends with their kids and then you,
you become friends with these people that you would never be fucking friends
with this.
This is what I do is I just look straight ahead and I don't look at him,
I don't respond to what they're saying.
And then they just sort of the talk quieter and they gradually leave.
You're going to have to go to dinner with them and your wife's can be friends
with some lady.
You're going to,
well let's go on a double date.
Okay fine.
You're going to go this one guy now he talks and he doesn't look at you.
He tells me these fucking stupid stories about his kid and the basketball team
and he looks at you for a second.
So,
so Adam's in his basketball and then he starts looking down.
He's in that did the coach won't put them in the game and I'm saying like if
he's a good player,
she could play,
how can we not can put them in the game and he's fucking bling rambling with no
regard whatsoever for your attention span.
The entertainment value of what he's saying.
He's just the underlying insecurity of not being able to look at you or he's
selling self-involved,
he's self involved and is doing some weird thing with his hands where he's like
click talking with his hands and I'm going,
Jesus Christ.
It's literally like someone squish,
fantasize about doing to them,
not just running,
just running away.
I don't want to hurt him.
The guy's hurt by life.
He's so damaged by live.
I don't want to do anything to them.
I just wanna get the fuck away.
I always picture those people and I have a giant roll of duct tape.
I just put it on the,
it's like a cartoon level speak.
No,
it's cartoon level.
I just put it on their mouth and I go,
and the last one,
it comes up and over their head and then it hangs down.
The whole rest of the tape is hanging down over there awkwardly.
And then I just go back to eating or whatever,
and they just sit there and slowly have to take it off.
There's some brutal fucking people.
It's,
you know,
there's a bunch of weird people that you,
you get closer to them and closer to them and you find out about their life.
Yeah.
But you know,
when all those people,
I want to do that too.
I'm sure they're talking about me,
so.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
I'm sure they talk about me too.
That's just how it goes.
Seemed like he was in a bad mood all the time.
Yeah.
This is friend of Ron White's,
who's a friend of mine who,
uh,
the first time he met me he's like,
oh,
I don't know.
And Ron's like,
I'm telling you,
he's a good guy.
Like,
he's a dad too,
and we're all buddies together now,
but he's like,
I don't know.
I just,
I'm guarded.
I've been beaten down by some of these fucking basketball stories.
It's these assholes and tell you and my,
he could,
he's a good player.
He's a good player.
Did just want to put them in the game.
Okay.
Do you just,
you think of things that you would torture somebody talking about and you like,
I would never do this to you.
Why are you doing this to me?
You're not even thinking about verbal water.
Yeah,
like in your own little Guantanamo.
That's a great way describing like when is the dessert tray coming?
I would say I don't need dessert,
so what should we do,
Gary Vee,
let's wrap this up.
What should we do?
What should people do?
People should fucking stop complaining.
Right?
Good.
Call the fuck.
They are good call.
People should not listen to America.
Propaganda of fixing the shit they suck at.
They should be tripling down on what they're good at.
They should be competent in certain
areas,
but you're not going to become Beyonce or your bone structure is a certain way,
like you're not going to solve everything.
Your Iq can get a little bit better,
but don't worry about the incremental.
Figure out what you fucking puts you on fire and you're halfway decent at it.
If you're lucky enough right now to be listening and you're good at what you
like become tunnel fucking vision because there's way too many voices telling
you what and how.
And here's the other thing,
and this is the big one,
Joe,
because you have a humongous audience.
The biggest thing that I've seen dividends from have the conversation with the
person that's holding you back.
The reason most people who are listening right now,
we're not doing that thing is they're worried about the opinion of somebody,
usually their mother,
usually their father.
And the reality is is that your spouse may be the person holding you back and
you have to have that conversation.
Turn them off.
We have to get to a place where you're doing you because the number one thing
that scares the fuck out of me is regret.
And you're going to sit there at 72 and he going to say,
I wish,
I wish.
And whether that's money or spend more time with your family.
There's a million ways to do this.
Not everybody wants to buy the jets.
Not everybody wants to smoke weed on the beach in Bahamas.
Like everybody's got a different fucking thing.
Figure out what your fucking thing is and stop making fucking bullshit excuses
who the president is.
Your mom did this like,
like I missed it.
I had that idea for Uber.
Then why didn't you fucking do it Dick?
That's what I think.
Joe Margarel,
this is not about parties.
We're taking these people on.
We're bringing God back in even smaller.
That wasn't very religious like Trump has gotten religion learning about this
because let me tell you something.
Trump's not a devil worshiper and he loves God and he's been briefed on all this
and he's going to roll their ass up so the pedophiles better get ready.
I want to,
I want you to clear something up right now.
Look at that camera and tell everybody you're not bill Hicks.
So stupid.
Tell him you're not.
I'm not either.
Tell them.
Well,
number one,
people think there's a God damn conspiracy.
Here's what happens.
They think it's a flat earth too.
I take real stuff.
Notice Joe's done is researched,
not kissing his ass.
So he knows all these little points.
I May,
he'd better than I even did.
I'm like remembering stuff when he brings it up.
Cause I tried to suppress half this crap.
I can't handle it anymore,
man.
I'm 43 and I'm sitting here looking at all this and then,
and these people come up to me on the street and they go,
hey Joe,
hey Joe.
Something like five times.
And then I,
I tried like,
Oh,
I knew you were,
you know,
were were,
uh,
I mean,
not just Jones,
Alex,
whatever,
whatever your fucking name is Alex Jones.
The program is Jerian killing.
I say Bill Hicks.
Oh,
they say,
here's the,
I'll be on the street or I'll be at a restaurant and they come over and they go,
they say,
hey bill,
hey bill.
Hey Bill.
I,
they don't really show Rogan.
And,
and I'm,
and I turn around and go,
oh,
I know it's you all because I did a few pieces and one little video with a guy
that lived in Austin that you knew that's how I met you,
but you don't like Bill Hicks.
That's what's ridiculous about it.
Like what'd you get?
Like massive plastic surgery changed the way your voice sounds like your voice
is so different than his,
all the testing is that no one ever wants to look real conspiracies cause
they're complex and hard to understand.
They want to just go with the earth is flat.
Uh,
you know,
there's aliens living underneath the capitol.
Dinosaurs aren't real or,
well,
no,
I mean,
listen,
the point is I'm look at a bash.
Eddie.
Eddie has,
yeah,
it's good to have a free open mind,
but he doesn't promulgate stuff.
He's only researching what's been said.
So I want to just get this out of the way.
I am Bill Hicks.
I'm actually,
you are how old Bill Hicks be?
Like 60.
Um,
I think he died at 32 and 1994.
So,
uh,
do the math.
I know one thing it's hot in here isn't really,
I don't,
I'm not hot.
You hot?
Nope.
I was getting my studio it really cold.
Oh dear.
Well you get,
you get crazy.
You're a Goddamn Elton inferno.
I'm melting.
Yeah.